Some of the things that will decrease inflammation, so you think of just the standard, something
like ice, could that help?
Yeah.
So cryotherapy, coldness can be beneficial to decrease the pain.
Also, even something like a tens unit, a stimulant, tens unit, stimulates at a certain waveform
to stimulate a confluent and a dwarf in production that could be natural pain relievers.
Also, things like that are natural anti-inflammatories like Boswellia, Ginger, Curcumin, Stiggy
Dental, those kind of things could be good, but you have to take those in fairly high dose,
but those could be beneficial, but we're talking about your curcumin, you really want to
get up to probably five to six grams a day of curcumin.
Five to six a day for the curcumin.
Okay.
Does heat help at all?
I mean, I use some heat and, you know, it's kind of a localized comfort, but doesn't seem
to have any lasting effect, but...
No, it's cold.
Heat and cold.
Sometimes if you alternate hot and cold and get a pumpy reaction, that might be more beneficial.
So everybody's a little bit different, so some people react to cold, poorly, and it seems
to make the pain worse.
Some people react to heat poorly and it tends to make the pain worse.
So you're going to have to just experiment with that.
Yeah.
That's kind of what I figured, too, so, yeah, that's something special.
Thank you for that, that way.
I just want to ask you, so do you sell any of these products on your site, the curcumin
or really...
Yep, so we have the curcuclear.
Yeah.
So the curcuclear is the best form of curcumin right now.
It's the hydrocurcumin, and what the capsule is equivalent to what grade.
So, and then we have Boswellia, and we have a product of our own mix that makes it a little
bit less expensive, called BAM, and it comes in at our BAM, it's body anti-inflammatory mix.
We first created it called it brain anti-inflammatory mix, but it's really good for your whole body.
It has...
All it is is anti-inflammatory, it's in there, and we sell it at costs, so it's a powder
kind of like mushrooms, if anybody's on the mushrooms, and tables full of that a day in a mixture
that could be very good anti-inflammatory mix.
I can't put that in with my perfusion drink.
Yep, you can.
Okay, well, I've got about six things that perfusion drink at this point, so I actually somehow
even with the chaga that we've gotten, as I spoke to last, it hasn't changed the taste
much, so the first green, I think it's what it's called, that really helps to keep the flavor
in line.
Yeah, but it is funny with the chaga, because even for a couple of hours in the fridge,
I go back to September more, it is like coffee grounds and I respect, but they go down the
head, so that we've been going in, yeah, thank you for that, yeah.